la vaccination qui pourrait bientôt
devenir obligatoire ou plutôt qui serait
possible pardon aux enfants de moins de
5 ans en tout cas là les autorités
sanitaires aux états unis attendent le
feu vert de l'agencé des médicaments
pour lancer cette campagne de
vaccination à ce sujet sensible qui
provoque beaucoup de réactions autres
atlantique les précisions avec notre
correspondant à washington l'atom
abonnés
un comité d'experts de l'agencé
américaine des médicaments la f10 est se
réunit le 15 février prochain il s'agit
d'une procédure accélérée sur demande de
lagence puisque selon sa présidente
l'ouverture de la vaccination pour les
enfants de moins de cinq ans est une
priorité alors c'est un sujet sensible
pour les autorités américaines qui font
part d'une certaine prudence tout en
anticipant un avis favorable qui
conduirait donc à l'ouverture de la
vaccination pour les enfants âgés de six
mois à cinq ans et coûter le docteur
anthony fauci l'afd a examiné données
très attentivement elle sera très
prudente dans l'examen des données et
dans la formulation d'une recommandation
et d'une décision sur la base de ces
données je ne veux pas les devancer mais
bien sûr nous anticipons l'obtention
d'un signal d'efficacité du vaccin qui
permettrait l'utilisation de ce vaccin
chez les enfants de son côté le pdg de
pfizer explique que la vaccination des
tout jeunes est nécessaire pour faire
face dit il à aux hospitalisations
croissante des enfants il indique que
trois doses seront nécessaires et qu'il
s'agira de doses adaptées selon la
tranche d'âge mais à un débat existe sur
la balance bénéfices risques de la
vaccination pour les plus jeunes
d'ailleurs preuve que l'opinion n'est
pas totalement convaincu sur la tranche
des 5 11 ans moins de 30% actuellement
été vaccinées aux etats unis et puis la
confiance dans le vaccin qui se joue
aussi dans un tribunal américain avec
cette procédure dont on vous parlait
déjà il ya quelques semaines qui voit
s'opposer une organisation de médecins
oeuvrant pour la transparence en matière
de santé publique et la f10 l agence
américaine des médicaments la justice
avait tranché il ya quelques semaines
pour une publication accéléré des
données ayant mené à la validation du
vaccin pfizer aux etats unis une
publication plus rapide que ce qu'avait
initialement demandés l'agencé
américaine des médicaments puisqu'elle
avait demandé un délai de 75 ans est
finalement la justice lui donne
seulement quelques mois pour le faire il
ya quelques jours donc pfizer est
intervenu dans cette procédure l enjeu
pour l'entreprise en tout cas selon ses
avocats c'est de s'assurer qu'aucune
information confidentielle ne sera
dévoilée dans le cadre de cette
publication écouter
failli leur soutien la publication de la
vaste majorité de ces informations pour
promouvoir la transparence et la
confiance de l'opinion dans le vaccin et
pfizer demande à intervenir dans le seul
but de s'assurer que des informations
dont la divulgation est interdite ne le
soit pas de manière inappropriée
du côté des plaignants on estime que la
motion déposée par pfizer est prématurée
et que l'entreprise ne devrait au mieux
à quai dès la fda l'agencé américaine
des médicaments respecter les délais de
publication imposées par la justice aux
états unis